liebe Soldatinnen und Soldaten dieses
Jahr sind bemerkenswerte Entwicklungen
im Kampf gegen das Coronavirus gelungen
man denke an die in Rekordzeit
entwickelten Impfungen aber leider
können wir trotzdem auch dieses
Weihnachtsfest nur eingeschränkt feiern
die heurigen Weihnachtstage sind aber
auch für sie geschätzte Soldatinnen und
Soldaten ganz besondere Tage sie erleben
ihre Weihnachten im nahen oder Mittleren
Osten in Afrika oder am Westbalkan
ihnen wird es daher nicht möglich sein
die Weihnachtszeit mit ihren Familien
ihren Leben und ihren Freundinnen und
Freunden zu verbringen
trotzdem hoffe ich dass sie im Kreise
ihrer Kameradinnen und Kameraden etwas
Zeit und Ruhe finden können um das
Weihnachtsfest zu begehen ich danke
Ihnen allen von Herzen für ihren Einsatz
durch ihren Einsatz schenken Sie vor
allem der Zivilbevölkerung in den
Konfliktregionen dieser Welt Frieden
Freiheit und Sicherheit auf ihren
engagierten Einsatz können wir
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher sehr
stolz sein sie werden International sehr
geschätzt für Ihr professionelles können
ihre Verlässlichkeit ihre
sprichwörtliche
Improvisationsfähigkeit und für ihre
Menschlichkeit vielen vielen Dank dafür
und danke auch ihren Angehörigen die Sie
gerade jetzt in schwierigen Zeiten aus
der Ferne unterstützen ich wünsche Ihnen
allen frohe Weihnachten sowie ein gutes
und friedvolles neues Jahr und für die
restliche Dauer ihres Einsatzes wünsche
ich Ihnen persönlich und im Namen der
Republik alles Gute kommen Sie gesund
wieder nach Hause